- So, we're gonna just--
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- I'm Gia.
- I'm Zach.
- And we own Beetle House,
the restaurant and bar.
- And today...
- Today we are adults,
baking with an Easy Bake Oven.
- This is gonna be a...
- Real gourmet.
- I never had one of these as a kid.
Maybe that's why I'm bad at cooking.
- Yeah.
- Yeah!
I wanna see what the fuck
is up with this thing.
- The problem is, is that we
can only make it this big.
- That's it?
- Did you think you were getting
fucking four course
meals outta this bitch?
It's supposed to be an
appetite for a child.
- We'll scramble an
egg on this plate here.
We have to mix the cheese in with the egg.
(whistling)
I'm gonna crack that egg right there.
Throw it in.
- Can you bring it over here?
I just gotta do a technique, here.
- (laughing) That's not a technique.
(Gia laughing)
Come on.
- Po&p it open.
Just use the spoon to tap it.
- Oh.
- It literally says, press spoon.
(laughing)
(both shouting)
- Now we've just basically got
a little bit of an
egg-cheese omelet thing.
- Are we gonna get salmonella?
- Most definitely.
- Do we just use one?
We're from Illinois, though.
- Yeah!
- Chicago area.
We should've done deep dish for our fam.
- Ooh!
- I think we should go against
the rules and do deep dish.
We're gonna fuck this up, aren't we?
- Let's add two!
- Let's see, we're gonna take this,
and just put it over the pan, right?
Yeah, we'll do it like this, okay.
- That looks great.
- Say cheese!
- Cheese!
- Okay, this looks like a butt cheek.
It looks like my butt.
- We're gonna try to put
a little bit of this egg.
You know what we didn't do?
- What did we not do?
- We didn't spray the pan.
(record scratch)
It's a rookie mistake.
- Oh, wait, what's this?
- [Both] Oh, shit.
- Okay, wait, undo it.
(laughing)
Re-spray it.
Ooh, beautiful!
Very gentle on the spray.
Love it.
Put the butt back in, great.
- Go ahead, spray.
Okay, good.
- Pizza sauce.
- I'm not gonna eat this.
- We'll do half one, half another,
for the sauce hater over here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Sorry.
Don't get it on my half.
- Well, in the oven we go.
So, are we supposed to put it,
wait a minute, are we
making that clearance?
- Next!
I wanna put one on each
side as, like, two nips.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
That's so cute.
Perfect!
- I guess that's it.
We're cooking, I think,
I heard some sizzling sounds.
- Can I do it?
- Yeah.
(gasping)
Why are you so dramatic?
- It doesn't fit.
- So what do we do while we wait?
- I don't know.
I wish there was a way to, like,
see what was happening,
'cause I'm not gonna know
if it's overcooked or not.
- Well, there's not.
- Maybe we just need one.
- Hold. (laughing)
- Alright, well, we tried.
- Round two.
Ooh, I hear sizzling.
- I smell it!
- Smells like eggs and cheese, yeah.
- We gotta make sure
it cooks, because look,
we don't wanna get food poisoning.
- I'm not eating this.
- Where'd the other pep go?
We had two peps on there.
- This...
- Is not cooked.
- We're gonna re-put it
in for a little longer,
'cause right now it just looks like
garbage.
- Yeah, no.
Wait, come here.
Pepperoni lovers.
- Three? No!
This is the point, is
that it was not going in,
because it's too tall.
- Okay, so we're over
the 13 minute mark, now,
so, we need to push this guy through,
and see what we're working with here.
You ready?
- I'm ready!
Ooh!
- Oh, not too bad, huh?
- Cool pepperoni idea.
Cool.
- Just shove it?
- Just push it.
(laughing)
- Ew, this is disgusting.
- Alright.
It's in.
- Put your thing up there.
- Up here, right here?
Okay.
- This one's called Breakfast Kiss-adilla.
Eat at your own risk.
- Uh-oh.
I hear sizzling, is that normal?
Something is burning, I can smell it.
Ooh!
Where are all the peps that you put on?
- Oh, there they are.
This biscuit is still not done.
- Maybe because you keep, like,
cloaking it in pepperoni.
- Now, let's eat it.
- Go ahead.
Does it feel crispy?
- Yeah.
- Does the egg feel cooked?
- Feels crispy, I mean,
I feel like the egg has to be cooked.
- Try it.
- No.
- Try it!
- You!
You're literally eating dough.
- Just an egg quesadilla and cheddar.
- Ay, oh, ba-da-bing!
- Ay! Ay! Oh!
- Yeah, something's burning.
- Uh-oh!
(oven hitting the table repeatedly)
Easy Bake is not easy.
Also...
- It's also not easy.
- That's literally what I just said!
- Cooking in an Easy Bake Oven sucks.
- Yes, but,
it can be done, technically,
and it didn't come out bad,
I mean, it's not ideal.
- Basically, we fucked this up big time.
I think that if you use a regular oven,
this would be fantastic.
All that work for this?
- We could each have a bite.
- A bite.
- I just don't think cooking's for me.
- I don't think it is, either.
But I love the Easy Bake Oven,
I'm glad I got to try it.